من الرياض ينضم الينا مدير المركز الجامعي
لطب وابحاث النوم بجامعه الملك سعود
الدكتور احمد بهمام دكتور احمد حياك الله
كل عام وانتم بخير رمضان كريم اولا بدايه
هل يعني بالضروره دخول شهر رمضان المبارك
حتميه اضطراب ساعات النوم لدى الصائمين
لدى كل الافراد
مساكم الله بالخير
شهر رمضان في بعض الدول ومنها المملكه
يصاحب تغيرات في نمط الحياه
مما يشجع على السهر بالليل والنوم النهار
مثلا تاخير ساعات الدوام من الانشطه
الليليه المختلفه ايضا استمرار البعض
الاكل طوال الليل كل هذه الامور تؤثر على
الساعه البيولوجيه للجسم وقد تؤدي الى
تاخير في النوم وهذا طبعا التاخير الحادث
انه وحتى لو استمر خلال الشهر كامل
على عمليات الايض او تمثيل الغذائي وما
يتبعها من زياده خطر الاصابه بالسكري
والسمنه
ومتلازمه الايض وايضا على القلب على
الاوعيه الدمويه على ضغط الدم على خطر لا
قدر الله ايضا الاصابه وغيرها لان هناك
اختلال حاد في خلايا الجسم المختلفه التي
تتبع ايقاع يومها او ساعه بيولوجيه جميع
الخلايا فيها جينات تتبع ايقاع يومي هذا
الاقتراب يؤدي الى مثل هذه التغيرات في
احد الدراسات الامريكيه ذكرت بانه الفرد
في العمل يتحسن عندما يحصل على قسط كافي
من النوم الجيد وقالت ايضا
هذه الابحاث اثرت ان النوم يؤثر ايضا حتى
في مستويات الجوع والشبع هذه كيف نقدر
نربطها بفترات الصيام اللي تصل تقريبا ل
13 ساعه في اليوم يا دكتور بمعنى هل الشخص
الذي يحصل على نوم وقسط كافي من النوم
ممكن ان تتعزز لديه يعني مساله الشبع وان
يعني لا يضطر ربما للجوع خلال ساعات اليوم
هناك توصيات وطنيه سعوديه من هيئه الصحه
العامه والوقايه بخصوص مده النوم الصحيه
جميع الفئات العمريه
كان مده النوم الصحيه في شهر رمضان هذه
التوصيات اوصينا باربعه الى ست ساعات نوم
ليلي خلال ليالي رمضان وتعويض ذلك بعد ذلك
في النهار بساعه ونصف الى ساعتين حتى يحصل
الشخص على ما يحتاجه من حوالي ثمان ساعات
شخص البالغ
النوم الليلي يقلل من الجوع بالنهار وهذا
امر ايضا معروف ومثبت بعد نوم ساعات كافيه
ثمان ساعات لا يستيقظ الشخص وهو يشعر
بالجوع البقاء مستيقظ الشخص طوال الليل
يزداد معه الجوع وهذا ايضا مثبت علميا
يزداد الجوع يزداد افراز هرمون الجوع
الكويلين ومقاومه الجسم هرمون الشبع
الليبتين ايضا هناك ابحاث كثيره منها نحن
عملناها التعرض للضوء خلال الليل الضوء
الساطع طوال الليل ايضا يفتح الشهيه ويزيد
في تناول النشويات والكربوهيدرات
والسكريات مما يسبب وبالتالي يا دكتور
احنا هنا نفهم انه يعني من ينام بشكل كافي
ياخذ قسط كافي من النوم خلال ساعات الليل
مبكرا اليوم الاخر في يوم الصيام لا يشعر
بالجوع مثل الشخص الذي ظل يعني سهران طول
الليل نعم قد يكون يعني نعم يفسر بهذا
الشكل ايضا هناك التوصيات بس نقطه اخيره
انه يكون الوجبات يعني وجبه افطار او حول
وقت الافطار وجبه سحول وقد يكون بينهم
سناك خفيف ونوم بعد ست ساعات بين الوجبتين
هذا امر اساسي للصحه العام